Off.
Quand Einstein travaillait sur sa théorie
de la gravité, tous les scientifiques de
son temps avaient une foi indélébile en
la mécanique Newtonienne.
D’ailleurs, lorsqu’une anomalie dans la
trajectoire d’Uranus fut détectée, les
théoriciens suivirent aveuglément les pas
de Newton, et, plutôt que dénoncer sa théorie,
préférèrent expliquer l’anomalie d’Uranus
par l’existence d’une huitième planète
dans le système solaire.
Et aussi fou que cela puisse paraître, comme
nous en avons parlé dans l’épisode 2,
ils avaient raison ! Et Neptune fut alors
découverte.
Off.
Du coup, quand on découvrit que la trajectoire
de Mercure n’était pas tout à fait une
ellipse, personne ne doutait de la théorie
newtonienne.
Urbain le Verrier, qui avait prédit l’existence
de Neptune ave succès, préféra expliquer
l’anomalie de Mercure par l’existence
d’une neuvième planète du système Solaire,
entre Mercure et le Soleil, qu’il appela
Vulcain.
Cependant, le jeune et audacieux Albert Einstein
sortit des sentiers battus et se posa la question
que personne n’avait osé poser : et si
cette anomalie n’était pas causé par cette
9ème planète ? Et si cette anomalie était
en fait la preuve que la théorie de Newton
n’était qu’une approximation, un développement
limité, d’une théorie de la gravité plus
fondamentale ?
Off.
En 1912, Albert Einstein se rendit à Zurich
pour retrouver son ancien professeur de mathématique
Marcel Grossmann, et partir en quête d’une
équation à travers de laquelle la matière
dicte à l’espace-temps sa courbure.
Assez vite, Grossmann proposa à Einstein
une équation.
Mais à la fois Grossmann et Einstein finirent
par la rejeter, car elle ne semblait pas être
à même de prédire les trajectoires que
Newton savait prédire.
Off.
Au lieu d’insister sur cette équation,
Einstein fabriqua sa propre équation.
Toutefois, submergé par la monstruosité
des équations en jeu, Einstein échoua dans
son calcul de la trajectoire de Mercure.
Mais comme leur théorie unifiait de très
belle manière la relativité restreinte et
le principe d’équivalence, Einstein et
Grossmann étaient en fait assez contents
de leur équation.
Ils la publièrent donc en 1913, et demandèrent
aux expérimentateurs de la confirmer…
en partant en quête d’éclipses solaires
!
Off.
La théorie de la gravité de Newton ne s’applique
qu’à des objets ayant des masses.
Elle ne s’applique donc pas à la lumière,
car celle-ci n’a pas de masse.
Cependant, dans la théorie d’Einstein,
la gravité courbe l’espace-temps, et cette
courbure déforme l’espace à travers le
temps.
Or, la lumière se déplace à travers l’espace.
Donc, cette déformation de l’espace affecte
la trajectoire de la lumière.
C’est ainsi que la trajectoire de la lumière
nous paraît courbée depuis la Terre.
Off.
En particulier, lorsque l’on observe une
éclipse solaire, la position des étoiles
derrière le Soleil doit différer de celle
dans le ciel la nuit.
Et c’est cette déviation qui devait être
la confirmation de la théorie d’Einstein.
Cependant, les éclipses sont rares, et elles
ne se réalisent qu’à des lieus et des
moments très spécifiques.
Mais surtout, la 1ère guerre mondiale envahit
toute l’Europe, et le monde.
Ceci ralentit drastiquement l’avancée des
expéditions qui cherchaient à confirmer
ou réfuter la théorie d’Einstein et de
Grossmann.
Ce fut une grande déception pour Einstein…
à moins que…
Off.
De façon ironique, ces échecs des sciences
expérimentales furent un miracle pour la
carrière d’Einstein.
En effet, en 1915, alors que les expérimentateurs
étaient encore dans l’incapacité d’effectuer
leurs observations, Einstein découvrit que
ses calculs étaient erronnés !
Off.
Pris de panique, Einstein chercha à réparer
sa théorie.
Pendant ce temps, le plus grand mathématicien
de l’époque, le grand David Hilbert, partit
à la poursuite d’Einstein, en se lançant
à son tour à la quête de l’équation
tensorielle qui pourrait expliquer la trajectoire
de Mercure.
Quelle angoisse ce fut pour Einstein ! Il
travailla dur.
Très, très dur.
Mais il restait coincé et à cours d’idée
! Sa propre théorie de la gravité semblait
en train de lui filer entre les doigts.
À plusieurs reprises, il crut avoir tout
résolu ! Mais il finit encore et encore par
trouver des erreurs dans ses calculs.
Et, à tout moment, Hilbert risquait de le
griller sur la ligne d’arrivée !
Off.
Dans un acte de désespoir, il reprit l’équation
que lui avait proposée Grossmann, comprit
que les arguments qu’il avait avancés pour
la rejeter étaient infondés, et la modifia
légèrement pour garantir la conservation
de l’énergie.
Il contempla cette équation et fut saisie
par son incroyable beauté, sa surprenante
élégance.
Elle avait tout pour plaire !
Off.
Il était alors tant de lui faire passer le
test final.
Cette équation allait-elle permettre de prédire
la bonne trajectoire de Mercure ? Pour répondre
à cette question capitale, Einstein se lança
dans des calculs laborieux, difficiles et
interminables ! Il passa des jours et des
nuits, à calculer, calculer, et calculer
encore.
Et encore.
Quand, tout à coup…
Il trouva la bonne réponse ! Après des pages
de calculs abstraits et difficiles, Einstein
avait déduit la trajectoire de Mercure de
ses équations ! Enfin, il avait dans ses
mains une théorie qui prédit mieux les trajectoires
des planètes que ne le fait la théorie de
Newton.
Il avait raison ! Il avait triomphé !
Off.
Pendant les jours qui suivirent, il eut de
dangereuses palpitations cardiaques, dues
à son excitation extrême.
Il écrivit : “Les années de recherches
angoissantes dans l’obscurité, avec leurs
alternations intenses et interminables d’instants
de confiance et de moments de fatigue, et
l’émergence finale dans la lumière — seuls
ceux qui l’ont vécu peuvent comprendre…”
Même si je n’ai jamais rien découvert
qui soit ne serait-ce qu’un iota de ce qu’Einstein
a découvert, cette citation raisonne beaucoup
avec moi.
Quand je fais des maths, quand je cherche
à prouver des nouveaux théorèmes, ou quand
je cherche à apprendre des théories bien
établies comme la relativité d‘Einstein,
la plupart du temps, je suis complètement
perdu.
99% du temps, je ne comprends juste rien à
ce qui se passe.
Et puis parfois, de façon souvent très inattendue,
une connection se fait tout à coup dans mon
cerveau.
Et là, et là, c’est l’extase.
C’est juste incroyable ! Il y a alors tout
à coup des torrents d’idées qui envahissent
mon cerveau et tant de choses s’éclaircissent
d’un coup ! Et je dirais que le plus gros
problème de l’éducation, surtout en maths,
c’est que la quasi-totalité des étudiants
ne vivent jamais cet instant fantastique…
Off.
Des années plus tard, en 1919, Sir Eddington
confirma la théorie d’Einstein à l’aide
de l’observation d’une éclipse.
Étrangement, Einstein le prit quasiment comme
une anecdote.
L’anomalie de Mercure l’avait déjà convaincu
de la validité de sa théorie.
Mais pour le reste de la Terre, c’était
la plus belle nouvelle qu’ils avaient entendu
depuis bien longtemps !
Off.
Alors qu’ils faisaient encore le deuil des
victimes de la première guerre mondiale,
les médias et le grand public à travers
le monde trouvèrent enfin une raison de sourire,
alors qu’ils célébrèrent la chute des
vieilles idées de Newton, et l’avénement
de la nouvelle théorie révolutionnaire de
l’espace, du temps et de la gravité par
Einstein.
Off.
C’est à l’issue de cette excitation unique
dans l’Histoire des sciences qu’une nouvelle
génération de physiciens émergea, et développa
une théorie antagoniste pour les échelles
microscopiques, la théorie de la mécanique
quantique.
Mais ça, c’est pour une autre fois…
Off.
Depuis, la théorie de la relativité générale
n’a cessé d’être confirmée.
Gravity Probe B a montré qu’une toupie
en orbite tourne exactement comme l’aurait
prédit Einstein, tandis que des rayons laser
envoyés depuis le bas jusqu’au haut d’une
tour ont confirmé la dilatation gravitationnelle
du temps prédite par Einstein.
Et puis, plus récemment encore, il y a eu
la détection des ondes gravitationnelles,
comme en parlent Florence Porcel et David
Louapre.
Du coup, de nos jours, on a une confiance
telle en la théorie d’Einstein, qu’on
l’utilise pour localiser les amas de galaxie
en mesurant leur effet de lentille gravitationnelle,
et pour nous localiser à la surface de la
Terre à l’aide de la technologie GPS.
Mais au cours des dernières décennies, deux
découvertes ont montré que la théorie d’Einstein
ne collait en fait pas avec les observations
du cosmos…
Off.
D’un côté, les galaxies tournent plus
vite que ce que l’on croyait, alors que
les galaxies distantes s’éloignent de nous
en accélérant.
Ceci montre qu’à l’échelle des galaxies,
la courbure de l’espace-temps est plus grande
que ce qu’Einstein avait prédit, mais qu’à
l’échelle intergalactique, la courbure
de l’espace-temps se fait dans la direction
opposée à ce que disent les équations d’Einstein…
Est-ce que ceci prouve qu’Einstein avait
tort ? Et bien, comme il y a 100 ans avec
la trajectoire de Mercure et la théorie de
Newton, les physiciens ont une telle confiance
en la théorie d’Einstein que, plutôt que
de remettre à plat la théorie, ils cherchent
à expliquer leurs observations par l’existence
d’objets non-observés dans l’univers.
À l’échelle des galaxies, ces objets non
observés sont appelés matière noire, alors
qu’à l’échelle intergalactique, on postule
l’existence de l’énergie noire.
Mais il ne s’agit que de mots inventés
pour l’occasion.
On ne sait pas du tout de quoi ça s’agit.
Tout ce que l’on sait, c’est que si la
matière noire et l’énergie noire sont
bel et bien présentes, alors la théorie
d’Einstein devient à nouveau parfaitement
consistente avec les observations.
Cependant, on ne peut pas exclure la possibilité
que ces anomalies soient des indices qui nous
suggèrent qu’il nous faut chercher une
théorie
de la gravité, plus fondamentale encore
que celle qu’Einstein avait découverte…